savez vous que l'on recense en moyenne
2000 700 séismes par jour dans le monde
est la plupart sont imperceptibles sans
instrument nous ne ressentons que les
plus forts alors qu'est-ce qui fait
trembler la terre je vous explique la
surface de notre planète ressemble à un
puzzle elle est recouverte de plaques
les fameuses plaques tectoniques qui
s'emboîtent les unes dans les autres
comme les pièces d'un puzzle ces plaques
bougent dans permanence de quelques
centimètres par an au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle des failles elle coulisses les
unes contre les autres ou bien ses
cartes en surface ça ne se voit pas mais
le sol accumule détention jusqu'au
moment où ça finit par céder la rupture
provoque des ondes de choc qui se
propage dans le sol et qui sont à
l'origine du séisme pour mesurer
l'énergie libérée par un séisme on parle
de manipuler plus l'énergie accumulée la
longueur de failles sont importantes
plus la magnitude est élevé plus gros
séisme jamais enregistré était de
magnitude 9,5 il s'est produit au chili
en 1960